con la bandera ucraniana ondeando de
nuevo el presidente bolodimir zelenski
llegó para celebrar lo que ha sido una
de las mayores victorias de Ucrania en
la guerra hasta el momento la retoma de
gerson
capital regional que los rusos habían
ocupado desde el 2 de marzo pocos días
después del inicio del conflicto
[Aplausos]
Este es el principio del fin de la
guerra porque ya ven nuestro fuerte
ejército estamos avanzando paso a paso
por nuestro país por los territorios
temporalmente ocupados por supuesto es
una pena que el camino sea largo y
difícil
el 11 de noviembre Celestia anunció La
retirada de las tropas rusas y que
ejerzó volvía a estar bajo el control
ucraniano un logro que se debe en gran
parte a la ayuda proporcionada por la
otan y los aliados occidentales de kiev
que le han suministrado artillería y
misiles de alta precisión y que todo el
mundo celebró en persona no obstante las
autoridades ucranianas han pedido
precaución y han dicho que todavía no es
seguro volver a la ciudad ya que los
rusos podrían volver a atacar y la zona
está plagada de minas
el precio de esta guerra es muy alto
muchas personas resultaron heridas y
muchas murieron creemos que nuestro
ejército rodeó al enemigo y los rusos
estaban en gran peligro hubo una lucha
feroz y este es el resultado Hoy estamos
en gerson
Y es que esta guerra ha dejado a gerson
en ruinas con necesidad de ayuda
humanitaria y bombardeos que aún se
escuchan Rusia asegura no haber perdido
ni uno de sus 30.000 soldados y que La
retirada solo es parte de una
reorganización estratégica tras la
visita de celenski El kremlin dijo que
jerson sigue siendo rusa ahora el río
nieper actúa como frontera entre los dos
bandos de la guerra